1 dibs with her know this ok - lets go
we got a couple bleeps there's no bleeps
if you believe this perfect know if you
you know no more bleeping all right I
don't live in a Trump world okay I live
in a [ __ ] an American world where we
don't [ __ ] it edit we just [ __ ] do it
I know that's my plan yeah whatever okay
no more editing okay we're just gonna
keep it as it is all right
I haven't said anything controversial
okay I am just asking questions because
I am a free thinker and also I am
Descartes say I don't know what did date
card say George what a Descartes say
let's stop here I'm gonna ask the [ __ ]
I don't know he said do you know who who
is what wax ask him a question and then
if you pay him 50 bucks if he knows oh
that's right that's right that's right
who was Descartes he's a journalist no
okay what is he that's it here let me
show you the spelling first maybe it'll
know it's not kind of he is a full-blown
good guy
does he have are you he was gonna say
[ __ ] take heart was have you heard the
existentialist philosophy philosophers I
don't know they are okay but but
Descartes was considered with him
Kierkegaard Sartre you know they they
were like but he Tico was the one of the
earlier examples of existentialism and
he he did a book on meditations he wrote
a book on meditations and in the
meditations I think there were 13 of
them right
he created the thirst the famous
statement I think therefore I am
okay by and that is that's pretty
sellable you exist because you think he
doesn't even know how English works
I said before I am and he goes translate
no you said it wrong
I think I'm pause I think comma
therefore I am okay oh where there was
also
what was the comments on foot on YouTube
they say about crack do Bobby yes sir
last oh yeah yeah yeah there's gonna
hurt my feelings
yes because you [ __ ] up about the
Godfather it wasn't even Godfather one
the second one it was the second one
yeah Fredo who cares Godfather universe
it doesn't say that he's the only
brother that betrayed that might
question what to you was what brother
betrayed Michael Corleone you didn't
know the answer my the answer is Fredo
enough said is that what the [ __ ]
message is about maybe perhaps okay
whatever looks like you have some cracks
in your game too don't really nothin
your Beatles game huh
because I'll tell you why I say who
loves the Sun right the reason why I
said that was because the Velvet
Underground in their fourth album
bloated right it's the opening song
right and here comes the song is the
opening song you know it's the second
song on Abbey Road which is so they're
both albums I listened to as a kid and I
think that people would you know realize
that I got mixed up but it's not you
know I mean as sinful as not knowing
that Fredo betrayed Michael Corleone and
you guys right now alright right are
screwing around the fact and trying to
point fingers right and I'm not saying
anything of I want him to grow I want
this which Gilbert overt now right
that's his damn right yeah over I want
Gilbert to grow and that's why I'm hard
on it I see it now and no and that's why
I'm I get on your case about things
because III don't want people to think
that you're [ __ ] no one thinks that
but you okay listen guys we've been at
this what 60 episodes 66 I whatever I
feel I feel like we've got something
going
hmm I feel like we're a team finally
yeah I do
possibly do okay we I have people now
going other comedians going hey yeah I
wanted your podcast which is a really
good thing I've never asked anybody and
so as a team we need to work together
and we can't lie to each other
and we have to be transparent okay and
also we have to help each other grow so
you're right I should have known
okay that it was Godfather 2 which I
already [ __ ] know okay but you should
know who decart is I know and that's all
no I know
okay I think therefore I want even to
say that why not even bring up the card
I forgot I think therefore I am
I have no idea either no idea but um you
know that's that
[Music]